you must have with someone before you
marry them some people actually believe
to make sure if it's good these people
want physical intimacy without emotional
intimacy it's an excuse not to commit no
one like that ends up getting into a
very happy marriage because all they
have done is emphasize the overwhelming
pleasure and it's just one more reason
not to have a loving intimate
relationship usually those women are
like what if he has a three inch with a
Barb on the end of it and I don't find
out till my wedding night something
outrageous like that that is just
overwhelming the other piece though is
this is one more excuse to not get
married people will have five children
and three dogs and buy a house and move
to another country and give their
partner one of their kidneys but will
not get married because the concept of
becoming responsible to another human
being and being legally vulnerable in
any way shape or form terrifies them
that's not to say that anybody that has
before they get married is inherently
going to be a bad marriage partner it's
the people that proselytize about it to
others that it's something which you
must do that is another quite dark Amber
flag